well different parts of the valley see
in different case loads earlier this
year
our eye team showed you which zip codes
had the most cases
tonight the map looks different our own
david sharon is here now with the update
new at six and the incentive to get more
and more people vaccinated
yeah brian so we looked at new cases
over the past eight weeks compared to an
eight-week span that we saw
during that fall surge where we had a
lot of new cases every day so we put
these maps for you side by side
and by the way we did put all of this on
eight newsnow.com right now also inside
our app so you can search
your zip code but this is pretty much
what we're seeing right now i want to
point out that the red
means more cases and you see here back
in october
in november we're seeing a lot here in
the northeast valley
right now it's pretty much in the
southwest valley specifically
89148 you're actually seeing the most
cases the past eight weeks
nearly 900 there alone some parts of the
northwest and north valley though we're
seeing
pretty much the same amount of cases
that we saw back in the fall and now but
in general those cases shifting from the
north
to the south and southwest part of the
valley now health leaders say these
cases are being fueled by the
unvaccinated as you just heard in
christian's report there people who
haven't gotten the shot
and now there is a plan to incentivize
you to get one if you haven't
and you'd get a hundred dollars
commissioner tick sagerbloom says the
county could budget 10 million dollars
from the hundreds of millions it got
from federal coronavirus relief that's a
hundred thousand people in clark county
getting the vaccine
and that money the commissioner says as
more and more private companies require
vaccines or proof of a negative test
this just makes sense the reality is
employers are going to start saying we
want you to either
be vaccinated or get tested on your own
dime
every week or twice a week so i mean
there are going to be some financial
penalties involved whereas if we give
you this hundred dollars
then you make money as opposed to have
to pay money all right so all of this
will be talked about at the commission's
meeting coming up on tuesday of course
we'll
keep you posted on that again you can
check your zip code right now
on eight newsnow dot com